moi je n'ai jamais touché à ce moment là
aucune ni depuis lors nulle part dans
d'état aucune prime en liquide
donc c'est quand même bizarre cette
histoire à moins que le ministère de
l'intérieur soit à l'époque un état dans
l'état avec des pratiques qui sont des
pratiques chaque ministère avait ces
pratiques il est vrai que l'on s'ennuie
son intérieur eu des pratiques peu
différente de celle des autres ça cette
petite phrase sibylline avec un petit
sourire sibyllin pas du tout parce que
safari la police mais maintenant mais la
presse en diamant y compris les journaux
de droite s'interroge sur cet argent
d'entre eux écoutez moi je moi je met
moi je m'interroge pas je n'ai aucun
élément de ce dossier une chose est
certaine je connais claude guéant depuis
une bonne vingtaine d'années j'ai
confiance dans son honnêteté je sais sur
le sens de l'état donc ce dont je suis
sûr c'est qu'il n'a volé cet argent à
personne un peu après laissons-le
enquête suit son cours dans suis quand
même très étonné de la judiciarisation
croissante du débat public
c'est dès qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'un côté on voit sortir de l'autre côté
des bribes de des bribes denquête des
bribes d'instruction des appartements
jamais mais les appartements mais je
pense que j'ai assez que là aussi vous
avez des bribes on parle d'une de
tracfin mais en même temps tout ça est
extraordinaire en matière soit on met
tout sur la table soit on attend que le
dossier soit bouclé après on juge de la
vraisemblance de ce que fait le juge
d'instruction de skype je te décides de
juge d'instruction comme dans le cadre
de l' affaire bettencourt
mais mais mais cette ces petites bribes
qui sortent ces petits morceaux nos
forces il ya le mur décombres lendemain
on a droit à une bribe denquête sur
claude guéant moi j'ai rien à dire je
supplie telepath dossier la seule chose
que j'ai à dire c'est que c'est un homme
honnête et qui a le sens de l'état mais
vous savez que sa mère visée politique
mais bien sûr respectivement maintenant
les gens disent voilà c'est reparti
l'ère sarkozy l'argent l'argent faller
sarkozy l'argent l'argent même si vous
permettez
si vous perdez l'ère socialiste l'argent
de l'argent je vous rappelle pas ce qui
s'est passé comme si c était au pouvoir
auparavant et ce qui se passe depuis
qu'ils sont revenus bon donc il y en a
qu'on en a parlé moins de kahrizak on en
parle aujourd'hui même s'il n'ya pas de
pros
ces partis caf s'est pas tout à fait la
liseuse là on est on est pas du tout
dans le même genre de deux sujets on n'a
pas tous les éléments et il n'a pas de
compte en suisse enfin bon voilà comment
j'y ai cru hier le placide vous regardez
vous poser une question
duby juge juste de sur ce point une
dernière question tout ça il ya quand
même dans votre camp des commentaires
notamment d'une ancienne ministre ex
collègue de claude guéant qui traite ou
qui a traité claude guéant ou de menteur
ou de voleurs moi j'ai déjà dit ce que
je pensais de madame bachelot de son
comportement
c'est marrant parce que elle trouve un
an que c'est un voleur elle a accepté de
siéger à ses côtés au gouvernement elle
s'est roulé par terre pour être ministre
jusqu'à la dernière seconde tout ça est
d'une indécence elle incarne pour moi
l'absolu indécence en politique fort
émue de continuer à faire le clown à la
télévision ça fait peut-être rire
certains moi ça m'a jamais fait rire
mais voilà je vous passe de ces
commentaires en tout cas moi je m'en
passe